so leute die zeit sich zu verabschieden
ist gekommen scheint ich will das jetzt
gerade wieder wir haben freitag den 28
vielleicht wäre es jetzt 11 u 13 und wir
machen uns auf den weg um dänemark
dieses wunderschönen fleckchen an dem
wir untergekommen sind burg zu lassen
und es wird einfach viel zu krass ich
das auto eigentlich recht schade das
wird wieder dänemark verlassen müssen
weil sie wirklich wirklich schön ist
andererseits freue ich mich auch mal
wieder auf einer nacht in der ich nicht
zu wenig schlafe deswegen jetzt mit
gemischten gefühlen zurück in
deutschland und im heutigen blog wird es
auch mit den ersten schott der richter
robert brück gegeben die über 10 km
lange übers offene wasser geht das wird
richtig geil und nochwas 3 2 1
a
13 43 wir sind jetzt schon nach drei
stunden unterwegs ist gerade hier am
tanken und irgendwie sind ein paar
gestörte menschen soweit läuft alles gut
es regnet recht stark gerade hier in
dänemark es regnet stark in denen
zwischenstopp in flensburg wir haben
getankt und ich habe mir kaffee brot und
ich hab mir und belegte brötchen geholt
und man die hörnchen für die fahrt denn
wir haben noch flotte sechs schon vor
uns wir durchhalten baum und ihr was zu
essen was zu trinken
ambassador weitermachen wir haben jetzt
15 55 21 48 gerade
wann genau jetzt ihr wissen unter der
elbe läuft ganz gut wir haben noch immer
noch vielen halbstunden kann das
raststätte irgendwo in buxtehude und
bleiben noch drei stunden bis zum ziel
bitte wo sie wie harz west
es ist 19 49 wir sind seit 11 unterwegs
glaube ich 11.30 knapp acht stunden am
tag drei stunden vor uns es zieht sich
doch deutlich länger als ich gedacht
hätte ja da hinten steht übrigens ein
polo auf marker seht ihr das hier weiß
nicht warum kann ich jetzt nicht näher
kommentieren schon mehr drin
eine kleinigkeit zum trinken
rang
volker petzold aus
20 37
es ist schon dunkel draußen sieht man
nichts dabei mich mal kurz hier nicht
ein bisschen wieder ganz gerade macht
wir brauchen noch brauche noch 50
minuten oder adria muss danach noch mal
zwei stunden zu sich nach hause fahren
deswegen hat jetzt überlegt dass ich
kurz musikauswahl wird überlegt das
adria noch bei uns getränke ich denke
viel die auch jetzt habe ich versucht
max zu erreichen max nicht da hab ich
versucht meine mutter zu erreichen meine
mutter ist auch nicht erreichbar bei
hertz ist die große frage wie kommt der
junge sein café damit das war nach hause
schafft touristik bietet sich hier die
basics in der maria leute ist es
geschafft wir sind endlich wieder zu
hause das heißt ich bin zu hause
adrian hat noch zwei stunden vor sich
ich kann mich jetzt erstmal ins bett
legen bisschen schlafen danke fürs
dabeisein beim road trip es liegt ein
bisschen anders als geplant wir sind
doch nicht nach schweden gegangen weil
die schweden sich nicht gelohnt hätten
davon abgeraten von den dänen ist wer
nicht so toll dass wir haben es nicht
gemacht habe alles in allem was er sehr
coole erfahrung ja macht aber kein
großes drama a 3 mio
oh ja
mann